[Musique]
c'est vrai que chacun votre tour vous
dit pour l'instant vous dit si le
meilleur élève et le moins bon élève
pour vous de ce début d'année
début d'année on est même au deuxième
trimestre c'est sûr on passerait pas en
classe supérieure la débauche je suis
sorti j'ai pour toi le meilleur et le
moins bon meilleur élève j'ai envie de
dire genton aujourd'hui j'entends c'est
une révélation pour moi et moins bons
élèves
j'ai envie de dire parce que je n'aime
pas sa tête c'est gilles verdez gilbert
dewey c'est totalement de mercy non mais
tellement je vous avais bien argumenté
voilà ça fait vous quelqu'un de bien
nicolas pernikoff alors pour moi l'art
pub je vous réserve c'est un peu
compliqué mais le meilleur élève pour
moi c'est gilles verdez qui est une
vraie révélation pour son retour
madrid et l'aubade élèves puis rien à
reprocher à quiconque à cette table donc
je trouve que tout le monde mais quand
on sait pas on démonte ya une bonne
équipe c'est une éclipse et une super
idée alors meilleurs élèves pour moi
c'est chez g et plus mauvaise élève
c'est bernard montiel mais vraiment sans
hésiter suce boules de la terre
n'importe quoi c'est pas quoi dire sort
des mots qui sort de nulle part de son
cerveau est insupportable film c'est
vraiment le nul vous savez pourquoi
parce que ça s'est mal passé tout à
l'heure en loge mais voulait mais quand
même mais j'adore en tout cas savait
recevoir vos habits il n'en est vraiment
pas pour ça qu'il est bon je suis
honnête avec mes amis gilbert dette
le pire oui c'est mon cas elle
franchement cyril vous adorent mais
comment faites vous pour le faire venir
chaque soir j'adore bernard montiel
d'alléger un problème selon lui oui
c'est mon petit chouchou oui mais c'est
le roi des branleurs
il ne travaille jamais y arriver ne sais
même pas ce qu'il va dire oui c'est le
vide incarner évidemment c'est le pire
isabelle morini bosc
alors moi le meilleur c'est guillaume
genton elle veut pécho elle aussi je
suis même pas je suis pas d'accord avec
lui et ça arrive souvent le trouve
toujours pertinent étayé est toujours
calme à croquer le mât contrario parce
que je vais pas me désigner moi même
parce que vous savez pas que des fois je
lis ton caddie remet donc pour moi le
pire c'est gilles parce qu'il est
toujours surexcité et pour mille à côté
ça me gonfle toujours jeunes
téléspectateurs et 2h13 enfin conseils
de classe et d'un enfant qu'on a fait un
conseil de classe on a perdu deux
chroniqueurs de car ces dernières que
va-t-il se passer
qu'est ce qu'il ya et de coeur c'est
bernard d'accord merci bernard montée je
veux dire moi je travaille énormément
mais j'arrive pas à en placer une
donc c'est toujours un peu difficile cc
regarder je travaille mais bon je trouve
que le toujours les autres s'expriment
mieux que moi donc je n'ose pas y aller
c'est vrai on sait qu'elle plus mauvais
et même mois non non vous pouvez pas
dire ça sinon moi j'ai du charme mais
j'ai du charme et ça n'a rien à voir
[Rires]
alors le meilleur pour moi de loin j'ai
eu déjà dit c'est guillaume genton je
trouve charismatique il est plutôt
stylée même si c'est souvent ridicules a
vraiment une très très très belle recrue
est le pire pour sa oisiveté et parce
qu'il me fait mourir de rire à toutes
les émissions et que c'est très très
compliqué de contenir les fous rires
c'est bernard montiel
oui ça aurait fait rire mais c'est juste
extraordinaire en tout cas il ya
vraiment deux qui ressort pour deux
qualités complètement différente un mois
la meilleure élève c'est delphine c'est
une très belle période et le marais vo
et on n'est pas là pour quelque chose
taris mekla ces professionnels et le
pire je sais pas quoi dire dont je veux
dire montiel c'est gratos et 25 est
l'enfoiré je retire ce que j'ai dit et
vous avez vu un pur pour les
chroniqueurs le meilleur chroniqueur
c'est guy roux jean thomas et le moins
bon c'est pas ma faute et je vais
demander aux twittos ce que nous donnait
également meilleurs éléments prono
milliard seulement pas courts les tweets
bon on va pas donner moi juste le
meilleur voilà je vous dirais alors
c'est nicolas pernikoff pour moi le
meilleur non alors moi pour moi le
meilleur
franchement c'est gilles va de chouilly
je dis la vérité
oui j'adore rio mais pour moi c'est
bernard angulaire la pierre angulaire et
l'agencé il vigilant c'est benjamin
mais voilà la norme et moi alors blake
se disent je n'ai pas de préférence
jauzion c'est comme si vous demandez de
choisir entre mes enfants je vous jure
que c'est vrai c'est vous aime tous pour
des qualités différentes mais je vous
aime tous
je trouve vous êtes un très bon travail
cette année tous non et je vous jure que
c'est pas une démagogie je le pense
vraiment pense vraiment du brut est une
bonne équipe cette année voilà je vous
aime tous voilà et isabelle bien sûr
c'est ma petite chouchoute peuvent que
pierre je sais que chaque jour de prix
est important
[Rires]